quand j'étais petit garçon plein de vie
et de joie
ajoute que j'ai de très gentil mon père
tort rapportant un jouet extraordinaire
avec deux frères je les fais dans mes
bras et quand je les faisais pas il
faisait six ans il roule attendu tourné
pour garder le marché je ne sais pas
c'est que j'ai fait six mois que je ne
saurai
jamais donné la première fois
j'ai poussé là et dans ma fraise 6-2 2-1
mais quand je vais
attaquer tôt
je ne sais pas
mais
il passe à souge ses cuisses ou d'un
liseré ce défi j'ai pleuré que son père
et sa fille et aux éclats car en le
retournant je vis que jouini était
derrière moi et justin theroux des
enquêteurs mais habile marché flipo
toutefois je ne sais pas c'est que
j'espère les autres que je ne saurai
jamais
joué
justement hier dans le premier cercle
ce soulèvement du maire
j'ai un peu l'air mon petit garçon et de
lui refaire il était vieux qui vous bien
quand on l'imposé pas perdre il faisait
toujours sur dix roulait à caen qui joue
la ville marché je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas ce que c'est